next on public lives
James Glick discusses his biography of
Isaac Newton it's 40 minutes for
tonight's speaker we're very happy to
have James click here and as you
probably know James click is the author
of several books faster about the
relationship of our relationship with
time both psychological technological
and historical time
genius the life of life and science of
Richard Penniman what just happened to
Chronicle from the Electronic Frontier
and chaos which you're probably aware of
James Glick is the native of New York
City is a graduate of Harvard University
in the 1970s he's helped found a weekly
alternative newspaper in Minneapolis
called metropolis he worked for 10 years
as a reporter for the New York Times and
he lectured at Princeton University and
in 1993 co-founded pipeline a pioneering
internet service and he's here tonight
to discuss his book Isaac Newton Isaac
Newton has been called a beautifully
paced and very stylish year written book
a compact atmospheric and elegant work
and I'd like to have you join me in
welcoming to Olsen's James quick
thank you Mary I'm delighted to be here
at all since thank you especially all of
you for coming out in the middle of this
storm you were very brave I'm going to
read a little bit from my book but
before I do that I will talk a little
bit and I thought what I would talk
about is some things that I don't know
about Isaac Newton specifically I have
questions some of which I actually wrote
down on random lists in 1999 when I was
starting to work on this and which I was
never able to answer at least
satisfactorily and the thing is these
are not necessarily important questions
an important question might be why did
he have a mental breakdown at the
pinnacle of his career or how did he
discover gravity and what about that
Apple anyway I know the answers to those
questions at least I have some
understanding however complex and
imperfect the kind of question I'm
talking about is the kind that ought to
be easy there ought to be a specific
answer and it ought to be possible to
find it but I got stuck where the
information wasn't there and in fact if
any of you happen to know the answers oh
that's my nightmare but feel free to
jump up and tell me one did Newton ever
even see the ocean now maybe you wonder
how there could how there could be a
question about this or or maybe you
wonder why I would possibly care to
begin with Newton is famous for having
said a very few things besides the one
about the shoulders of giants the most
famous is this you don't have to listen
too carefully because it's gonna come
around again later I do not know what I
may appear to the world but to myself I
seem to have been only like a boy
playing on the seashore and diverting
myself and now and then finding a
smoother pebble or a prettier shell than
ordinary whilst the great ocean of truth
lay all undiscovered before me this
quotation first turns up in a book of
anecdotes published a century after his
death how it got there isn't exactly
clear but no biographer beginning with
David Brewster in the mid 19th century
has ever been able to resist using it
and I'm no exception but when I visited
Newton's childhood home a stone
farmhouse in a still very rural part of
England it suddenly occurred to me that
there was no beach anywhere around and
more to the point people weren't mobile
in the way we take for granted newton's
father was a yeoman farmer who could
neither read nor write
and he never travelled more than 10 or
20 miles from his birthplace Newton
himself went much farther in a lifetime
of 84 years he traveled almost as far
from his birthplace as I traveled last
night to get here he lived for several
years in Grantham a market town six
miles away from where he was born
then he lived in Cambridge eventually he
made his way all the way to London at
least once he took a small boat across
the river Thames to Greenwich and that's
it he never left England and as far as I
can discover he never saw the ocean but
there's no way to be sure he didn't in
the millions of words of notes and
scribbling and correspondence that he
left behind there's virtually nothing of
a personal nature who he met what they
said how he felt where they went
the famous quotation isn't the only
reason this ocean business bothered me
the ocean lose large in Newton's legacy
he thought deeply about the ocean
he was the first human being truly to
understand tides could he really never
have seen it
- did newton ever have sex
well this one's easier no he didn't
except again how can we ever know for
sure his contemporary and nemesis Robert
Hooke one of one of my favorite
characters in the book kept a private
journal in which he made clear that he
slept with various of his housekeepers
Hooke was very interested in his bodily
functions he had special notations for
his ejaculations and even his bowel
movements Newton however wouldn't have
been writing this kind of thing down in
any case he did occasionally make
private notes that reveal feelings about
sexuality and they are morbid suffused
with horror and disgust sometimes of a
religious nature when he was a fellow
and then a professor at Trinity College
Cambridge chastity was an explicit
requirement one of one of the
requirements that many of his colleagues
ignored when it suited them Newton
himself once wrote in a manuscript
fragment the way to chastity is not to
struggle with the incontinent thoughts
but to avert the thoughts by some
employment or by reading or by
meditating on other things and this too
is hardly what you'd call definitive
evidence of anything but a mood still it
does seem that he never had a lover and
not only that he never even had a friend
as we would use the term even in our
psychoanalytic era we hardly have words
for the kind of loner Newton was and on
this question of Newton in sex we even
have a witness of sorts the enthusiastic
young writer Voltaire
arrived in London just in time for
Newton's death and he wrote that Newton
had died a virgin he attributed this
information to Newton's doctors
but how would the doctors know and more
to the point given what people knew and
believed about physiology why would an
18th century reader of Voltaire think
the doctors would know I have some ideas
about this but mostly I'm in the dark
when he was growing up where was the
nearest clock the Newtonian universe was
a clockwork universe we all know that
the clock suddenly seemed like a perfect
metaphor for the cosmos we take clocks
for granted a generation before Newton
was born Shakespeare put a clock into
the ancient Rome of Julius Caesar
because he didn't have enough
perspective on the history of technology
to know that clocks were new but clocks
were new and in reality in 17th century
England a clock was a rare thing there
was certainly no clock in Newton's
childhood home or in any home nearby a
cathedral would have a clock a giant
mechanism and some churches but in rural
Lincolnshire that would be about it the
clockwork universe came later
I'm wobbling it's our universe but it
wasn't there for the young Newton you
start to realize that a clock would be a
big thing for him a talismanic object to
begin with a clock was a machine and
there weren't many machines of any kind
second it was a machine to do nothing
but mark time amazing concept the very
existence of a clock for that matter
implies a certain conception of time
scientific time you could call it time
as duration as a form of dimension
regular and measurable this is dominant
in our modern way of thinking and we
have trouble subtracting it but it's not
the way people thought about time for
most of history one thing that's clear
is the two items of special fascination
to Newton as a child were machines and
time a water mill was being built in
Grantham and he followed its progress
and constructed models of his own out of
wood and he became obsessed with
sundials it was said that if anyone in
the neighborhood wanted to know the time
they consulted Isaac's dials eventually
he even built a crude water clock and by
the way when we speak of clocks were
generally talking about the reckoning of
hours only not minutes and as for
seconds as a unit of time the word
barely existed
worst of all for a biographer what did
Newton look like here's a description
the wondrous Isaac he was 29 or 30 then
with a face like a purebred stallions he
was thin and strong and marvelous
energetic face like a purebred stallions
well I like that
unfortunately it's fiction it's from
John Barth's novel the sahte weed factor
there is no portrait or drawing of
Newton from when he was 30
the first portrait dates to 1689 when he
was 47
in fact it's here you can't see it from
where you're sitting but it's plausible
the problem is then come many more
portraits there are 17 extant not
counting copies and if I lined them up
here you would think they were 17
different people I'm also not counting
what you would call imaginative
portraits in 1859 Frederick knew enim
made a painting of Newton at age 12
about the same time a Japanese print was
made showing a well-dressed Newton
watching an Apple fall to the ground and
it has a caption Isaac Newton very great
head of school but not pompous most
famous of all is William Blake's Newton
golden-haired and naked with a body
you'd expect to see in a surfer movie
and this is especially wonderful and
strange because Blake hated Newton so
much for painting is pros any better one
biographer Lewis Moore says Newton's
most notable features are the power and
expanse of the forehead and the
appearance of concentrated meditation in
the brow and eyes the lower lip is
pinched and drawn in so that the
expression is one of excessive
cautiousness and one infers him too
you know to have been of a suspicious
and obstinate temperament well he had
that temperament alright but I don't
believe for a second that one infers
this from the portraits contemporary
descriptions were almost but not quite
non-existent and not just of Newton but
of everyone one of the few tidbits we
have comes from Newton's niece who says
he had a lively and piercing eye a
comely and gracious aspect with a fine
head of hair as white as silver without
any baldness and when his Peru quiz off
was a venerable sight well I liked the
lively and piercing eye but Bishop
Atterbury said Newton did not have a
lively and piercing eye he said in the
whole air of his face and make there was
nothing of that penetrating sagacity he
had something rather languid in his look
and manner which did not raise any great
expectations in those that did not know
him well painters can do either
nonfiction or fiction
I do strictly nonfiction so with a
standard item like a physical
description what is the poor biographer
to do can you write a whole biography
without trying to give a sense of what
the person looked like well at some
point I did my best but you'll have to
look hard to find it and I'm not going
to read it now I'm going to start at the
beginning
Isaac Newton said he had seen farther by
standing on the shoulders of giants but
he did not believe it he was born into a
world of darkness obscurity and magic
led a strangely pure and obsessive life
lacking parents lovers and friends
quarreled bitterly with great men who
crossed his path veered at least once to
the brink of madness cloaked his work in
secrecy and yet discovered more of the
essential core of human knowledge than
anyone before or after he was chief
architect of the modern world he
answered the ancient philosophical
riddles of light and motion and he
effectively discovered gravity he showed
how to predict the courses of heavenly
bodies and so established our place in
the cosmos
he made knowledge a thing of substance
quantitative and exact he established
principles and they are called his laws
solitude was the essential part of his
genius as a youth he assimilated or
rediscovered most of the mathematics
known to humankind and then invented the
calculus the machinery by which the
modern world understands change and flow
but kept this treasure to himself he
embraced his isolation through his
productive years devoting himself to the
most secret of Sciences alchemy he
feared the light of exposure shrank from
criticism and controversy and seldom
published his work at all striving to
decipher the riddles of the universe he
emulated the complex secrecy in which he
saw them encoded he stood aloof from
other philosophers even after becoming a
national icon Sir Isaac master of the
mint president of the Royal Society his
likeness engraved on medals his
discoveries exalted in verse
I don't know what I may seem to the
world he said before he died but as to
myself I seemed to have been only like a
boy playing on the seashore and
diverting myself in now and then finding
a smoother pebble or a prettier shell
than ordinary whilst the great ocean of
truth lay all undiscovered before me in
evocative simile much quoted in the
centuries that followed but Newton never
played at the seashore boy or man born
in a remote country village the son of
an illiterate farmer he lived in an
island nation and explained how the Moon
and Sun tug at the Seas to create tides
but he probably never set eyes on the
ocean he understood the sea by
abstraction and computation his life's
path across the Earth's surface covered
barely a hundred and fifty miles from a
hamlet of rural Lincolnshire southward
to the University town of Cambridge and
thence to London he was born in the
bedchamber of a stone farmhouse on
Christmas 1642 as the calendar was
reckoned in England but the calendar was
drifting out of step with the Sun his
father Isaac Newton yeoman had married
at 35 fallen ill and died before his
son's birth English had a word for that
the child was posthumous thought
unlikely to resemble the father
this first Isaac Newton left little
trace some sheep barley and simple
furniture he endorsed his will with his
ex for like most of his countrymen he
could neither read nor write he had
worked the land of wolves Thorpe a place
of woods open Heath's Brooks and Springs
where underneath the thin soil lay a
gray limestone from which a few
dwellings were built to last longer than
the common Hut's of timber and clay
a road of the Roman Empire passed nearby
running south and north a reminder of
ancient technology still unsurpassed
sometimes children unearthed antique
coins or remains of a villa or wall ii
Isaac Newton lived to be 84 Doughty
and rich he died in London at the end of
the winter of 1727 our prolonged and
excruciating death from a kidney stone
England for the first time granted a
state funeral to a subject whose
attainment lay in the realm of the mind
the Lord Chancellor
- Dukes and three Earl's bore the pall
with most of the royal society following
behind the corpse lay in state in
Westminster Abbey for eight days and was
buried in its native above the grave was
carved an ornate monument in grey and
white marble the figure of Newton
recumbent the celestial globe marked
with the path of a 1680 comet and
angelic boys playing with a prism and
weighing the Sun and planets a Latin
inscription hailed his strength of mind
almost divine and mathematical
principles peculiarly his own and
declared mortals rejoice that there has
existed so great an ornament of the
human race for England the continent of
Europe and then the rest of the world
Newton's story was just beginning the
French writer calling himself Voltaire
had just reached London he was amazed by
the kingly funeral and exhilarated by
all things Newtonian a Frenchman
arriving in London finds things very
different he reported for us it is the
pressure of the moon that causes the
tides of the sea for the English it is
the see that gravitates towards the moon
so that when you think the moon should
give us a high tide these gentlemen
think you should have a low one
it pleased Voltaire to compare Newton
with his nation's late philosophical
hero Rene Descartes for your Cartesians
everything is moved by an impulse in you
don't really understand for mr. Newton
it is by gravitation the cause of which
is hardly better known the most
fundamental conceptions were new and up
for grabs in coffee houses and salons in
Paris you see the earth shaped like a
melon in London it is flattened on two
sides for a Cartesian light exists in
the air for a Newtonian it comes from
the Sun in six and a half minutes
Descartes was a dreamer Newton a sage
Descartes experienced poetry and love
Newton did not in the course of such a
long life he had neither passion nor
weakness he never went near any woman I
have had that confirmed by the doctor
and the surgeon who were with him when
he died
what Newton learned remains the essence
of what we know as if by our own
intuition Newton's laws are our laws we
are Newtonian fervent and devout when we
speak of forces and masses of action and
reaction when we say that a sports team
or political candidate has momentum when
we note the inertia of a tradition or
bureaucracy and when we stretch out an
arm and feel the force of gravity all
around pulling earthward pre Newtonian
x'
did not feel such a force before Newton
the English word gravity denoted a mood
seriousness solemnity or an intrinsic
quality objects could have heaviness or
lightness and the heavy ones tended
downward where they belonged
we have assimilated newtonian ISM as
knowledge and as faith we believe our
scientists when they compute the past
and future tracks of comets and
spaceships what's more we know they do
this not by magic but by mere technique
the landscape has been so totally
changed the ways of thinking have been
so deeply affected that it is very hard
to get hold of what it was like before
said the cosmologists and relativist
Hermann Bondi it is very hard to realize
how total a change in outlook he
produced creation Newton saw unfolds
from simple rules patterns iterated over
unlimited distances so we seek
mathematical laws for for economic
cycles and human behavior we deem the
universe solvable he began with
foundation stones of knowledge time
space motion
I do not define time space place and
motion as being well known to all he
wrote in midlife then a reclusive
professor recondite theologian and
Alchemist seldom leaving his room in
Trinity College Cambridge but he did
mean to define these terms he salvaged
them from the haze of everyday language
he standardized them in defining them he
married them each to the others he
dipped his quill in an ink of oak galls
and wrote a miniscule Latin script
crowding the words edge to edge the
common people conceived those quantities
under no notions but from the relation
they bear two sensible objects and
thence arise certain prejudices by then
he had written more than a million words
and published almost none he wrote for
himself careless of food and sleep he
wrote to calculate laying down numbers
in spidery lines and broad columns he
computed as most people daydream the
flow of his thoughts slipped back and
forth between English and Latin he wrote
to read copying out books and
manuscripts verbatim sometimes the same
text again and again more determined
than joyful he wrote to reason to
meditate and to occupy his febrile mind
his name betokens a system of the world
but for Newton himself
there was no completeness only a
questing dynamic protein and unfinished
he never fully detached matter and space
from God he never purged a cult hidden
mystical qualities from his vision of
nature he saw order and believed in
order but never averted his eyes from
the chaos he of all people was no
Newtonian
information flowed faintly and Perisher
bleah them through the still small human
species but he created a method and a
language that triumphed in his lifetime
and gained ascendancy with each passing
century he pushed open a door that led
to a new universe set in absolute time
and space at once measureless and
measurable furnished with science and
machines ruled by industry and natural
law geometry and motion motion and
geometry Newton joined them as one with
the coming of Einstein's relativity
Newtonian science was often said to have
been overthrown or replaced but that was
not so it had been but rest and extended
fortunate Newton happy childhood of
science said Einstein nature to him was
an open book he stands before us strong
certain and alone yet he speaks to us
reluctantly and currently
thank you I would be very happy to
answer questions if anyone has any what
interests me at the moment I haven't
read your book is the quality of your
mind and so I have two questions one
what is it that that drives you in terms
of your selection of topic and how do
you engage that topic and why and - I
thought that was - no - is given the
reliance that you had on on the work of
the subject as our current technological
electronic mode of communication demise
of written sort of physical works what
do you foresee as as the research
approach or the way in which future
blake's are going to okay comment on
your life
that was at least that was at least two
questions now the first question was
something like how I choose my subjects
okay and my method of engagement I write
about things I'm interested in I'm I
mean I'm sorry if that sounds stupid and
obvious but what what else what else can
I possibly say I have a number of my
books have been about scientific things
I have apparently some kind of
congenital interest in science even
though I didn't study it in school
or in any official way I spent a lot of
time as a newspaper reporter and I and I
have picked a lot of subjects that
involved reporting and going around
traveling interviewing people but this
is an exception obviously because there
was no one left to interview so this
book was very different for me maybe
that's an indirect way of answering the
question of how I engage the subject not
absolutely sure what it means I mean in
this case I wanted to understand Isaac
Newton as a man as much as that was
possible and it's not that's not very
much because he lived a long time ago
and as I said at the beginning he lived
a very private life didn't talk to a lot
of people and didn't record personal
thoughts the way we tend to do now this
is in a way a roundabout way of getting
to your next question which is an
interesting one we believe and it may or
may not be true that people don't write
the way they used to we live in an
electronic age that's that's the premise
of your question it's certainly true
that we don't write with quills and ink
as Newton did
Newton wrote a lot millions of words as
I said and the record of what he wrote
very fortunately for the poor biographer
who has no one to interview survived
survives because he didn't throw things
out on the other hand he didn't they
were buried for a long time and all of
Newton's papers buried in the the attics
of English nobility who kept them hidden
and they only started to surface in the
last century well what's gonna happen in
the future when the Newtons of our time
who haven't written millions of words
with pen and ink die honestly I don't
subscribe to the theory that things are
going to be more difficult for future
biographers because willy nilly we are
saving a lot of information in a lot of
different formats there is so much more
information available about anyone today
then then there is about Newton it's
true that I was very lucky and and
scholars who study Newton's science have
been very lucky to have such an amazing
amount of detail in his hand but we
don't hear Newton's voice we don't have
the kind of printed record that we have
for scientists today who publish
immediately and publish on the internet
and send email much of which is recorded
some some email is lost but most of it
never goes away so that may not be the
answer you want to hear but I'm not
ready to shed tears for the future
biographers of people who are alive
today
barely ever published so how did he
become so famous he lived a long life
and the story of the story of the
various publications of his well each
story is interesting in itself and I
tell some of them in the book and the
story of his first great work the
Principia his most famous book in the
most influential book well it was only
published because his friend
Edmund Halle after whom the comet is
named dragged it out of him
persuaded the Royal Society to be its
publisher but he couldn't persuade them
to pay for it Halle paid for it out of
his own pocket
Halle took care of correcting proofs and
basically forcing Newton to write the
thing he published it reluctantly not
which is not to say that he didn't want
to be appreciated he did it's just that
he discovered that whenever he let his
work out people would argue with it and
say you know no I don't think the world
works that way and he he had a short
temper and couldn't tolerate that he did
become famous because he was right about
so many things and even in his time
his greatness was recognized so he died
a very famous man well as as as you
heard me say but not because not because
he published in the way scientists today
published there was only one journal in
England the first and it only it was
only born in Newton's lifetime and some
of his letters appeared in it but very
few scientific papers and almost no
books the rest of it came later well
in different ways at different times of
his life when he went to Cambridge as a
student he was in the very poorest
category of students which was a sizer
whose job it was to wait on tables for
other students who who came from
wealthier backgrounds by then his mother
had remarried and she married a fairly
wealthy man he didn't have access to
that money but in the end he did have us
the family farm to fall back on none of
which was really how he made ends meet
in the long run he became a professor at
Cambridge at a at a very early age he
only the second professor of mathematics
they ever had the first professor of
mathematics had only had the job for
about three years and stepped down in
favour of Newton when he was still in
his 20s so he had a secure income then
later he took a civil service job as
master of the mint I say a civil service
job facetiously the funny thing about
being master of the mint in England was
that you actually got to keep a
percentage of the money you coined so
Newton became very rich at that point so
that's beyond making ends meet convinced
were you of what you described as heresy
his flirtation with Arianism and
his denial of the Son and the Holy Ghost
being truly God I see that you listed at
least part of his argumentation and well
what do you mean how convinced was I
well did that I mean was I convinced
that he was right about God mmhmm yeah
were you personally did you buy his well
just you know to to bring everybody up
to speed here in in brief Newton much
more than he studied physics as we would
now call it studied the history of
theology he was possibly the foremost
biblical scholar of his time another
thing that no one knew me no one knew
this until long after he died he spent a
lot of time studying the ancient texts
in various languages and and he was
doing all this with a passionate purpose
he had a strong belief about a
particular point of Christian dogma
namely the Holy Trinity now
I don't really want a lecture on
Christian dogma here but in some Newton
rejected the idea of three of God in as
three equal persons the Father the Son
and the Holy Ghost he believed that
there was one God and that Jesus and the
Holy Ghost were subordinate to God I
can't gauge from the audience reaction
whether you are shocked or four-board by
that concept at the time though it was
it was beyond shocking if his views on
the subject had been known he would have
lost his job and he could have lost his
freedom this was this was not a joke
this was heresy and he had to keep his
views on the subject secret but but they
were strongly held beliefs I mean he had
a true passion for this subject now the
question which has taken me aback a
little bit was am I persuaded well no I
mean yes and now I have some I have a
good friend who's has guided me a little
bit on this subject and he's a strong
believer in the Trinity and he has tried
to explain to me how Newton could be
wrong
I think Newton was clearly right in a
factual sense about what the texts said
that is there is no evidence in
Scripture in favor of the the the
Trinity there was as Newton believed a
corruption of the texts in the third and
fourth centuries ad
as for what the reality is well you
haven't even asked me whether I believe
in God in the first place and that would
be a prerequisite for having a strong
opinion on what exact form he or she
takes next question imagine some sort of
Nexus science and his beliefs I think
the right way to answer that question is
to say that he saw no gap or distinction
between science and religion first of
all there was there wasn't really such a
word of science not the way we use it
but but mainly he was trying to
understand everything there were no
dividing lines in his thinking between
one area of knowledge and another he
wasn't thinking okay for a while I'm
going to think about theology then I'm
gonna put that aside and study physics
he was trying to understand the workings
of the universe I think in some way he
thought he had a a divine Miss mission
to do that not that God spoke to him you
know the way he speaks to people in
movies but but in some other way
I don't I don't know how to answer that
was he satisfied with himself he doesn't
seem to have been a particularly happy
person he was a proud man he as I said
never believed that he had completed his
search for knowledge on the contrary he
thought he was leaving a world of
unanswered questions I mean I think the
famous quotation that I read to you
twice was whether or not it was
apocryphal sincere that he did recognize
that the vast ocean of truth lay
undiscovered before him thanks
apparently I'm signing books if anybody
wants if you'd like to get your book
signed if you make a line up this side
of the store thank you he'll move this
away
James glicks other books include faster
and what just happened his biography of
Isaac Newton is published by Pantheon an
imprint of Random House online at Random
House dot-com next week the story of an
American journalist sent to Africa in
the 1800's to find Christian missionary
dr. David Livingstone